there's dustin man the dodgers take the
field in front of this first game in a
four-game series between the dodgers
and the padres
omega got his first win of the season in
san diego last tuesday went six innings
first time in his career he's done that
and he struck out at career high eight
how about this wonderful snapshot of
baseball's future here to start this
game the electric 22 year old dustin may
and the spectacular
21 year old fernando tatis jr on a 1-0
pulls it in the ear to left
jack peterson moves back on it and tatis
the first down
trent grisham coming up
hits this one the other way sends
peterson back onto the warning track
he's got it
great play jack peterson for the second
out
that was some kind of play
very good catch out stretch glove on the
run
so two out nobody on manny machado
coming up
and it's almost that same exact pitch to
produce the same result to finish off a
10 pitch first
luis perdomo getting his first start of
the year game four overall for lewis he
gets grounded tim peterson takes low and
inside ball four so a lead off walk for
jock and boogie bets
on a one-two pitch
cracks one sharply through the left side
base hit the first two reach for the
dodgers against perdomo
two on nobody out here's cody bellinger
a one-two bellinger pulls it past first
base and into right off hosmer's glove
they're gonna bring jack peterson home
the throw goes into second and the
dodgers lead at one nothing
so cody bellinger with an rbi single to
open the scoring before perdomo gets an
out
bam hosmer and myers will hit in the
second inning
delivers and a ground ball up the middle
into center field for a base hit
tommy pham with a single to center as
the padres begin the second eric hosmer
coming up set and an 02 hosmer grounds
one up the middle chance it two muncie
to the back double play
that guy carnivores at the plate in the
third there's the o2 swinging a liner
over the pitcher and over second base
into center field for a lead-off single
muncie came over from his position at
second to try and get there but here is
the national league player of the week
fernando tatis junior city bats here
down a run with a man on third two out
first base open on 3-2
got him to chase strike three with a
breaking ball he clinched his fist in
victory knowing he struck out one of the
game's elite players and one out with
the bases empty for mookie betts he's
hit in nine of his last 10 games and he
will face matt strom here 2-2 pitch is
strike three over the inside corner kind
of guessing there and strom gets him
second strikeout for matt strom two down
number three here's the two-two pitch he
swings and lifts one of the air to deep
right field myers going over has room
has time and gets there to make the
running catch now manny machado who
based on last few at bats would rather
see anybody other than dustin mays
machado bloops this one down the right
field line mookie betts will lay it out
not make the catch but it doesn't get
far away from him as machado heads for
second base and he'll get their standing
in the bottom of the fourth dodgers one
to nothing
yeah turner
breaks his bat and bloops one into
center field for a base hit it do drop
in
as turner's a board with a single in the
center now muncie
sharply hit diving stop at least to
smother it by hosmer in a race to the
bag muncie wins it so now the bases are
loaded chants at a big inning here matt
beatty comes up
swinging a foul tip into the catchers
bit for strike three needed that first
strikeout for quantrill is the first out
here in the fourth inning that was edwin
rios coming up here's the one and two to
rio swing and a hard hit liner caught by
hosmer at first he'll bring it to the
bag and a double play
eric hosmer snags a line drive and
quantrill gets out of it faces loaded
nobody out for the dodgers they do not
score
fifth inning and austin hedges coming up
on a 1-0 he takes this right one-on-one
dustin may starting to show a little
more emotion fastball right down the
middle had you a high fly ball deep
center field's got a chance ball going
ball long on austin hedges car rushed
for his first of the year
this ball game is tied
anytime you can hit a home run against a
pitcher of this quality to tie the game
in the middle innings it's going to feel
good but right here and right now for
austin hedges add a little extra
moves into scoring position with two
gone in the sixth
with two outs eric hosmer is going to
get a chance
osman will line this one to left field
in for a base hit around from second
comes grisham he will score and the
padres take a 2-1 lead an rbi single for
eric hosmer puts san diego on top
not out of the inning yet
first and second for little myers
he swings
and lost it into short center field
bellinger cruising in he'll make the
catch and that will end the end
the second oldest park in the national
league
right down the middle strike three call
that oh man 3-0 to 3-2 to strike three
looking cal cuantra you are a keeper
turner takes one fake three-call
he thinks it was low and it was low in
and out of the glove of hedges
back-to-back case for quantrill two down
blake trying to get a tough hitter to
face right here to
second grisham at first
machado hits it sharply what a pick by
taylor to turn a double play
that is sweet for six for three
things that make you go hmm
this is gorgeous
a one hopper backhanded sliding to his
knees dodgers got a run before there was
an out tonight
nothing since
drew pomeranz will get the ninth inning
for san diego dodgers now are down to
their final out and aj pollock is in
fact going to come out of bathroom
that is popped up on the infield right
side hosmer straddling the line makes
the catch in the padres win
padres take game one of the four game
series and drew pomeranz comes on as a
one two three ninth inning